cbs sports lead golf analyst sir nick
faldo joins us now he played on the pga
tour with tiger woods and gave him look
at this picture his first green jacket
that was back in 1997 the masters nick
thank you so much for taking the time
you must have been relieved as we all
were to hear the good news that he
survived what are you hearing from other
pga players
yesterday and today well as you know
it's amazing on social media it goes
literally to all four corners of the
world instantly
and you know exactly as you will see
first of all you hear it we get we
we pick up the news and you go oh my
goodness and then it goes you see
the vehicle uh just about totaled and
you think oh my gosh your god
um and then you hear he's gone off for
to search straight into surgery
and then we hear he's well okay he's not
life-threatening so that's a good start
a vehicle quite possibly saved his life
yes
um you know he also
you know with this back i i saw him
walking on sunday after he
you know finished the prize giving and
he's walking very gingerly obviously
after his spiff back surgery
so can you imagine being shaken up with
that engine
he's trying to repair that as delicately
as possible then you'll literally shake
it up in a mixer
for uh you know 10 20 seconds whatever
it was so
did you have you happened to heard where
he was going or where he was coming from
at the time of the accident do you know
any details about i believe he was
heading out the door early he was off to
do a photo shoot i think with golf
digest he
was like he was you know seen the day
before he was doing some
some promotional stuff with celebrities
that sort of thing
so that's all i really know on on that
part
you know what can you tell us listen we
all know tiger woods has had
uh personal and professional struggles
on and off the golf course he certainly
is known for his resilience
what can you tell us about that it's
almost a bit of a cinderella story
because i remember
and i'm not even a golf person
necessarily but i watched that match
when he won with and little charlie came
and ran into his arms we'll all remember
that moment
what can you tell us about his
resilience
well that was for me one of the most
incredible things you know to go
to go 11 years between winning mages is
pretty rare very you know off the charts
but to go through what he went through
the physical struggles you know four
surgeries by that time to rebuild his
golf game
um you know obviously the life struggles
as well to maintain your nerve to come
back and his mouth is we know has got
extraordinary you know mind strength so
whether he can pull
through this i mean i would have thought
he's going to start with well physically
i'm actually very fortunate to be alive
i just want to rebuild my body maybe
just 45 years old now you know ben hogan
had this horrendous
car accident 49 1949 when he was 36
so you know at 45 you're kind of at the
tail end of your career anyway
and to actually shake your body up like
this
yeah and there's a dog in a seriously
long rebuild that sort of thing
hey if anybody's got the mental strength
to come back but i've thought that this
will be in stages
my life i want to look after my children
exactly everybody says
don't underestimate tiger i certainly
believe that i get so uncomfortable with
all the talk of when is he coming back
how can he come back we all just want to
make sure he's okay and that he can walk
again
what's your wish absolutely absolutely
let's start with
life first hey golf is second and then
competitive golf
is possibly a long way down the line to
rebuild to be
to be good enough to compete against
especially it's tough enough playing at
45 when you're playing against kids that
are 25
yeah right now what he's trying to do
but after going through this all we can
do is pray for him and hope that
he finds a way to rebuild himself and uh
you know if he does come back to be a
gulf again i think that would be
um quite extraordinary yeah right now we
just want to back with his family thank
you very much sir nick faldo for your
time this morning